Taiwan defies China electing a new
president Beijing labeled a separatist
Troublemaker this is from the NBC news
so China taiwan's vice president Li
Ching was elected as a new president
despite warnings from Beijing not to
support him labeled by China as a separa
troublemaker the election is seen as an
as a significant development in the
already strained relationships between
China and United States but with Taiwan
status uh being a sensitive issue lays a
victory extends the rule of the
democratic Progressive Party DPP and
marks the first time in taiwan's history
as a democracy that the same political
party has won three consecutive terms
however the DPP lost control of the
legislative which may constraint lay
policy options China's response to L
Victory remains uncertain but potential
actions could include military
drills trade uh restrictions on
Taiwanese companies and cyber attx and
even Bloomberg story comes out same day
from uh uh about Biden saying Biden says
us doesn't support taiwan's
Independence after vote Joe Biden said
we do not support Independence
clarifying that the US position on
taiwan's Independence following the
re-election of taiwan's democratic
Progressive Party which aims to limit
China's influence China considers Taiwan
as territory and hope that taiwan's vice
president Le chinte who maintains strong
ties with the US would not be elected
President Biden remarks however have
escalate escalated tensions in us China
ation regarding potential military
inversion pbd you did a poll of whether
you thought China would invade Taiwan in
2024 what were the results of that poll
do you recall let me let me pull it up
because I want to say was 7030 if I if I
remember they thought they were they
weren't I think 70 was this was a couple
days ago right I'm just interested in
what happened to that poll I'll give it
to you right now go ahead and give you
commentary I'll look forward but or
you're looking it up is here we go Tom
the there it is right there okay so it
was pretty close yes but what we know is
let's just start with the facts in 2024
there's more elections going what 40% of
the globe is having elections is that
the number so the world is voting okay
and you vote with your feet you vote
with your pocketbook and you vote with
you know hopefully against War right now
there's three hot spots going on around
the world we know about Ukraine we know
about Israel but we don't know exactly
what's going on in China and Taiwan we
know about the South China seas and
everything going on over there but what
happened in Taiwan W and this is
important because they basically said
China no thank you we're aligning
ourselves with the United States and not
they're not the only country that was
formly part of China or that part of the
world that is essentially aligning with
the United States and I'll show you with
that so they are not aligned with the
CCP that's what's going on in China I'm
sorry in Taiwan and China is not exactly
happy about this so much so the
Philippine prime minister and the
Philippines came out and they basically
congratulated the the new Taiwanese PR
uh um president China the CCP said be
careful Philippines quote unquote you're
playing with fire but here's what's
going around in the W rest of the world
they pulled 20 countries major
countries do you view the us or China
more favorably pretty interesting 20
countries 18 of which said they viewed
us more favorably than China the
countries Japan South Korea Israel
Poland India Italy Hungary South Africa
France Indonesia Greece Canada Brazil
Argentina Spain Netherlands Mexico
Australia and obviously the US the only
countries that align themselves with
China Nigeria and Kenya wonder why
because they probably gave them billions
of dollars of and bottom off now that's
what confessions of an economic Hitman
will find out what happens with Nigeria
and Kenya but even more importantly they
asked who do you say contributes to more
peace and stability in in the world the
US and China and they asked major
countries India they answered 70% us
33% China wow okay Japan 79% us
14% China in South Korea
74% us 133% China it's becoming clearer
and clear you need to pick a team are
you on team autocrat or are you on team
democracy are you on team team China
Russia Iran houthis Hezbollah Hamas are
you on team democracy in the Free World
with the United States pick your team
these are these are goes back to the
first clip at the very beginning of our
podcast today yep America First based on
what John Stewart said right so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
here